melted cheese on top of bread is that a
sandwich is the sandwich pizzas the
sandwich Ned unfortunately yes No
[Music]
you might love hot dogs you might love
sandwiches but is that hotdogs also a
sandwich today we're going to get to the
bottom of this once and for all let's go
I think hot dogs are sandwiches and I
think hot dogs are not sandwiches I
believe that hot dogs are sandwiches now
holding one sandwich but that is also a
sandwich and a hot dog hot dog is a hot
dog my friends the logic is that the
definition of a sandwich is some sort of
filling in between bread technically is
not in between is laying on the bread
I know colloquially we all know hot dogs
aren't sandwiches but we're a society
built on rules as it stands you have to
look at how the dictionary is written
it's like rectangles and squares squares
a rectangle but a rectangles not a
square just because you don't call a hot
dog a sandwich doesn't mean it's not a
sandwich it's still technically a
sandwich you just call it a hot dog
I gotta interject here cuz this is
driving me crazy I think that your logic
is flawed I think people and the way
language is you I bother you may have a
dictionary can I get my argument out
nobody is trying to argue that a hot dog
is not a hot dog that would be
ridiculous I'm just arguing that it is
also a sandwich you have commitment
problems my friend if you say that a hot
dog is a sandwich
all of a sudden anything can be a
sandwich we believe that an open-faced
sandwich is a sandwich correct avocado
toast yes okay so what about melted
cheese on top of bread does that a
sandwich is a sandwich so pizza is the
sandwich Ned unfortunately yes no if you
want a hotdog how will you tell that to
your friends I would say I want a hot
dog so hot dog is a hot dog not a
muhfucka sangwich you wouldn't say go
get a sandwich right cuz then what
happened because a hot dog is not the
most readily available image of a
sandwich does not make it not a sandwich
did you get in here
if pizza a sandwich no it is not is a
hot dog a sandwich [ __ ] no damn right
man you don't see you know sandwich is
sold in hot dog places you don't see hot
dogs sold in sandwich places
does not make the sandwich rules I
refuse to answer to subway you know it's
all about perception okay I honestly
don't even really like hotdogs so much
but I just don't think they're
sandwiches if you think it's about
perception versus facts then saying a
hotdog is not a sandwich it's just an
alternative fact I believe they have to
stand for things and once you start
making words encompass everything
society Falls to [ __ ] I get the other
side I get it but something about
calling a hotdog a sandwich just like
makes my blood curl I don't know what it
is I can't describe it scientifically
like in a dictionary like Jordan can but
sometimes you just have a really strong
feeling about things you just know
you're right and I'm right whatever bike
if Mary moves stir changes the
dictionary I'll change my side people
who think the hot dogs of sandwiches
this is the person whose team you're on
the person who's saying that pizzas the
sandwich if you believe the pizzas a
sandwich I can't help you it is
interesting they said you know something
in between breads kind of made me think
a little bit like what is a sandwich
what makes things things what is life
you know so Thank You Jordan
please hug sorry I just got sandwich on
you there